hey 42 here League of Legends is the
most played video game in the world
which considering it's only been around
since 2009 is quite an achievement
League of Legends has over 32 million
active players and 12 million people
play on a daily basis if you've never
played League of Legends before let me
give you a quick rundown long as it's
commonly referred to is a MOBA which
stands for multiplayer online battle
arena developed by Riot Games a company
started by a couple of entrepreneurial
gamers MOBAs are a sub-genre of real
time strategy games based off a custom
map for starcraft called Aeon of strife
there are a handful of popular MOBAs
namely Defense of the Ancients and
Heroes of Newerth but none come close to
the popularity of law a typical game in
a MOBA consists of two teams of five
players who battle it out on a map
containing free lanes the goal is to
push the free lanes all the way to the
enemy base eventually invading the
enemy's base on destroying their Nexus
to win each player chooses a unique
champion to play out in League of
Legends there are over 100 champions to
choose from each with their own set of
attributes and abilities players can
gain an advantage over their enemies by
last hitting minions securing kills
under cysts and slaying the various
monsters scattered around the map all
these give you and your team bonus gold
which can be spent on better items to
make your champion stronger more than
ten new League of Legends games start
every second and the loss servers
regularly supports over 5 million
concurrent players globally to put that
in perspective the top 100 games on
Steam have an average of 650,000
concurrent players all put together but
the numbers get even more mind-blowing
every single month League of Legends
players play well over 1 billion hours
of lull that's revering
edible considering that since 2004 halo
players have played accumulative two
billion hours over 90% of law players
are male and 85% are between the ages 16
to 30 Teemo the ever so annoying yodel
dies 6.5 million times a day that's 75
deaths per second the chant of you
getting a pentakill is just 0.05 percent
that's only once in every 1,500 games a
both pentakill there was once a
legendary kill awarded for getting six
or more kills in a row which is possible
if the enemy takes revive and teleport
but it has since been removed from the
game
riot is constantly adding new Easter
eggs to the game such as your team will
lose the game if they surrender after
the enemy has surrendered there is a
cupcake inside Caitlyn's trap destroying
the enemy Nexus grunty 50 gold but it's
completely useless because the game is
over the ingame clock skips from 7
seconds to 11 seconds every game
Vladimir has been nerfed more than 10
times since his release whereas trundle
has never been torched between 8 to 10
new champions are in development by riot
at any given time
Leona's passive sunlights does one less
damage to champions wearing sunglasses
such as vain when fit uses his ultimate
Chum the waters if the enemy is small
like an E and dies from the attack their
body gets eaten by the shark instead of
leaving a corpse on the ground like
normal there are four ninjas in the
league shen alkali Kenan and Zed all of
these champions have a special book
called ninja which reads this unit is a
flippin ninja ninjas are more effective
on their own so for every ninja on your
team beyond yourself
you lose one health Nidalee can turn
into a cougar she has a hidden passive
which grants her the power of the Cougar
this passive grants nearby allied
champions +5 experience every five
seconds
they are a lower level in Italy riot is
constantly releasing new champions for
two years in a row
riot played an April Fool's Day joke on
their players by announcing the release
of a new champion of the Manatee the
legend of Earth became so popular that
riot released a new skin for Warwick
Earth the Manatee woman the skin was
such a success that riot decided to
donate the proceeds from the skin to the
save the manatee club that's about it
for Easter eggs but here's some things
you might not know about the game that
might help you out in soloqueue turrets
do more damage to champions with each
successive hit
starting at 105 percent up to a maximum
of two hundred and twenty five percent
on its sixth hit and Beyond making a
mental note of when buffs such as golems
elder lizard dragon and baron nashor
Eastbourne can help you secure the buffs
before your opponents even realize
they're there the Blue Room red bar is
born every five minutes the dragon every
six minutes and Baron nasha every seven
minutes many champions have auto attack
timer resetting abilities meaning you
can auto attack then use an ability then
auto attack again in quick succession
for tons of damage a good example of
this is vanes tumble most beginners
under appreciate the value of last
hitting minions but perfectly last
hitting one minion wave gives you a
hundred and twenty four gold that means
that last hitting free minion waves is
worth more than a kill and here's some
fundamental tips that will instantly
improve your gameplay maintain constant
map awareness in between last hits and
whenever you can you should be looking
at your mini-map if an enemy is missing
from the map there's a reason for it
they're either dead jungling or coming
to gank you a handy tip is depressed hub
when you see an enemy missing to bring
up the scoreboard this will tell you two
things very quickly how many enemies are
dead and how many are visible on the map
the grayed out champions are mi a play
for your team not yourself this is one
of the major factors that separates gold
players
platinum and diamond level players you
should maintain the mindset that
everything you do in game is to aid your
team and not improve your KD a ratio
after all la is a team game and the pros
didn't get where they are today by
playing for themselves learn how to
counter pick and counter build some
champions are inherently weak against
others instantly giving you the upper
hand so instead of complaining when the
enemy picks Kassadin players Pantheon or
Talon mid and get an early no magic
mantle then watch as you wreck is face
this leads me on to my next tip don't
play a champion you're not good with
just because you're think they're
overpowered or counter another champion
the best way to get good at the game
quickly is to choose one champion and
only play that champion you're a lot
more likely to win a game if you know
your champion back-to-front than if
you're playing a supposedly okie
champion you're no good with use wards
lots and lots of wards wards aren't just
for supports every champion should buy
Ward's throughout the entire game don't
go mad but a well-placed ward around
your lane or in the enemy jungle will
save your life time and time again and
you will get free kills you wouldn't
have got otherwise don't forget
objectives such as towers and dragon
they all give global goals to your
entire team but loan which objectives
are most important and when you should
take them here is a general teal list of
objectives for most important to least
important Nexus inhibitors Baron Towers
dragon champion kills bots and finally
smaller jungle camps constantly find
ways to counter the enemy teams plays
for example if the entire enemy team are
trying to push bottom and four of your
teammates are defending bottom solo push
the top lane and try and take a free
tower most likely your team can defend
bottom for verse five with the aid of
their Tower meanwhile your team just got
a free tower if the enemy team send more
than one person top to kill you then
simply recall you've wasted the enemy
team's time which is a big advantage in
itself
the enemy midlaner gone to gank top try
to take the middle tower whilst they're
away towers are worth a lot more than a
kill but don't forget to warn your top
lane that there's a gank incoming but
league of legends isn't just for fun
it's serious business eSports is one of
the fastest growing sports and Lowell
has overtaken Starcraft as the world's
biggest eSport the 2013 League of
Legends World Championship doing an
astonishing 18 million unique viewers
which is more than a lot of traditional
televised sports Riot Games offered a
handsome two million dollar prize pool
which fourteen of the world's best teams
competed for a share of 8,000 fans
showed up to cheer for their favorite
team at the live event which was held at
the Staples Center in Los Angeles but it
was also broadcast all over the world by
the internet and on national TV in South
Korea where eSports is taken very
seriously by the majority of the
population when asked many League of
Legends players reported that they
actually prefer watching professionals
play than playing themselves it is even
rumoured that eSports could become an
Olympic sport as soon as 2020 League of
Legends as a competitive sport is making
a big splash in north america and europe
pro gaming houses are popping up all
over the world a gaming house is a
special house where a professional team
under their management lives permanently
so they can practice together around the
clock it may shock some people that so
much time and money is put into
professional gaming but nothing compares
to the games impact in South Korea where
eSports is nothing short of the cultural
phenomenon professional teams in South
Korea are backed by multibillion-dollar
sponsors professional league of Legends
players can earn close to 1 million
dollars a year that's more than some
Premiership football players in the UK
but playing at that level requires over
8 hours of practice every day 2 state
tournament level Korean teams are
strictly controlled by their management
to ensure they get the best out of their
players players must wake up early
workout at the gym daily
and go to bed at specific times teams
also have a handful of player coaches as
well as nutritionists and personal chefs
to ensure they are eating a balanced
diet it's an awful lot of dedication but
for many people playing games for a
living is a dream come true thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you